hi there i'm sure you've seen this paper
make the rounds it's called
mlp mixer an all mlp architecture for
vision
it's by ilya tolstekin neil halsby
alexander koleznikov and lucas buyer of
google research
this is not going to be a long video
because the concept is pretty
simple um these people
did i say others or just the four names
i don't remember
there are a lot of authors here all of
them deserve credit
this paper presents a neural network
that is just mlp so just feed forward
multi-layer perceptrons no convolutions
no attention mechanism is just matrix
multiplications
non-linearities normalization
and i think skip connections but that's
not really a layer is it
um so it appears we've come
full circle in computer vision going
from mlps originally
to convolutional neural networks some
pixel rnns
then vision transformers and by the way
this paper is going to be much more
understandable if you've read the paper
on vision transformers
because it's from largely the same
people
and does the same kind of experiments
and methodologies
and now we've come back to mlps turns
out the thing you've tried at the very
beginning you know
it works after all no i'm i'm kidding
so it's not just as simple as slap an
mlp
on to the problem and that works there
is a still a very specific
architecture involved right here
and also i think the paper is mostly a
lesson
in what you can do with scale and
that good architectures might be
good for a particular scale and not just
good by themselves so
the end result here is going to be that
this new architecture that the
mlp mixer architecture performs
adequately not state of the art not
the best but adequately at large scales
and it appears to benefit much more
from scaling up than previous
architectures
which raises the question you know what
happens if we go to
even larger scales but i guess that's
for another
day or year or decade so
let's just dive in uh this is the
the architecture the computer vision
architecture that is proposed it's a
classification architecture you see this
right here at the end there is like a
fully connected
layer and a class label and also
there is a global average pooling so at
the end you just collect everything
you've done
and you put it into a classifier and
that gives you a class label so that
means it's amenable to fine-tuning where
you freeze
the the representations that come out of
the model and all of this
this kind of stuff that you might
already know
at the beginning of the model you have a
picture and
like in vision transformer you're going
to divide that picture up
into patches so in this case you take
something like 16 by 16 pixels
as a patch and those become your patches
down here and now you simply operate
on those patches as you propagate
through the network so unlike
a convolutional neural network where you
sort of
shrink the resolution but increase the
channels here
we're just going to have one layer after
another
one layer as big as the last one stack
stack stack
and until the end so it is much
like a transformer of course the
difference between
this and the transformer is in how the
individual layer
looks so like in the transformer
first of all every patch is
fed through a fully connected layer to
bring it into
a latent representation so this right
here
these right here are the latent
representations there of a
size that you choose as a model builder
and that's going to be kind of the
latent size that propagates
through the network so this is done on a
per patch basis
and this per patch operations and you
know
uh in general these these sort of
repeated operations are going to be the
key
to this architecture right here so
every patch is projected using the same
uh function into the latent space okay
then we this is followed by n
of these mixer layers now what does a
mixer layer do
and here is where the core comes in so
in every layer you start out
with you know you've just seen here we
we had patches but now we have these
latent embeddings like this stuff right
here
this essentially is one
vector for every patch so every patch
you unroll the patches
like so and every patch gets you one
vector
right every patch in the image
corresponds to one vector
so technically this here
you can interpret this as a table so
that's what they do here
it's just the other way around right so
this this here is the lower left corner
this one is the patch right next to it
this one is the patch right next to that
patch and so on
and each patch has one two three
four and so on channels each patch is
described by
a vector of whatever how many dimensions
i guess something like 512.
okay and now if you traditionally
if you solve this problem and you said
well i have an all
mlp on all mlp
architecture for vision what you would
do is you would take that table
and completely unroll it into one vector
right so the the top
patch would then be here and then the
the blue patch would be next to it right
this
this blue patch right here and so on so
you would completely
unroll that that's the yellow patch
into one single vector and then you
would put a fully connected layer
on top of that that's not what we do
here we're doing
much more like what we would do in a
convolution
except that we only have filters of size
one by one
so there are two different
um two different in this mixer layer
there are two different
hash i say this modes of operation
first we do the following
we flip this table we transpose this
table
and so
that means every row here
is the same channel from all the patches
so it's always
channel one from all the patches in the
image
right so from all the patches i want
channel one and i'm going to feed that
through a fully connected layer i also
take
all the patches but channel two
so channel two from all the patches i'm
going to feed that through the
same fully connected layer in fact you
can see
these weights are all shared right here
so this is
weight sharing across different
channels so sorry across always across
the same channel
of the different patches this is much
like you know one by one convolution
so uh actually this one here
is more like a one by one convolution
but
it is weight sharing okay and that means
we have a picture we put it into patches
and in this layer what we care about is
connecting the same
channel not even sure how to
represent the same channel i guess
you can say you you want the same type
of
information since this this all
builds on the weight sharing of the last
layer right so this
fully connected layer right here it's
the same for every patch
so that fully collect connected layer
might look at the patch
and if there is something like a sharp
corner in the top left
uh corner of that patch it might put
that into channel one
so now all of the patches that have that
in the top left corner like some sharp
corner here
will have that in their first channel
okay
so now if i aggregate among the same
channels if i do this then
if the first channel here reacts
across the patches you know i can
aggregate all the patches
that have that feature because the
feature
producing map was shared okay so all of
this builds
on the fact that in the last layer
features were shared too
so here we share
the projection which means that the
channels in the
individual patches mean similar things
okay because they come from the same
function
and since they mean similar things we
now group by those channels
and aggregate or or compute over
all the patches in that particular
channel
and since that particular channel has
the same information you know that
sort of lets us compute on a on a
feature by feature basis
now also of course these weights are
shared
so um since these weights are shared
that means sort of on a meta level that
now i'm going to perform the same
computation
in all of those channels which means
that
now i can i can do the the reverse trick
again
and flip the table back into
patches and then do this
shared computation for all the patches
so ultimately i just have
number one one weight matrix
where i forward propagate all of the
channels individually but in the same
way and here i have
another one so that's number two i have
one
forward propagation matrix where i
propagate all of the patches
individually
but in the same way right and again
since i now have done the same
computation over here
that means that the result
here is going to be sort of distributed
in the same way across
patches now i aggregate this into the
patch location
and i forward propagate this this is
much more like a one by one convolution
right
so we simply take a patch and we apply a
computation
across all of the channels of that patch
and we apply the same computation and
that prepares
the exact same thing for the next layer
i hope that makes a little bit of sense
i have trouble articulating this
but it it does make sense when you think
about it
so it there's two phases you repeat
um you look you repeat two steps
in this step you look at your patch and
you say what kind of features are there
right and you put the features into
pre-defined categories so channel one
is you know feature one channel two for
feature two and so on
and then in this step you take a
look across all of the image so step
or step two is here within the patch and
step
one is actually you look at all of the
image
but only in that channel that means only
for that particular feature
and then you look okay where in all the
picture
is that particular feature you do some
computation
across where that feature appears and
how
and then you go back to step number one
or two however i labeled it here
i hope that helps a bit the mlp
is not really i didn't really say this
correctly you don't have one matrix
in fact it's two fully connected layers
that are separated
by a non-linearity um however this
yeah it it's not one weight matrix it's
it's two-way matrices they are shared
though
across channels or across patches
depending on the step
and that's it um that's the architecture
there is
as you can see layer norm you also saw
this here in the
diagram there is always the layer norm
layer involved here
is this yep and here
and there are skip connections as you
can see at the top
but largely that's the architecture
so
what does this give us if again if
you've seen the vision transformer paper
this is or the big
transfer paper all of this is extremely
similar in terms of architectures
what they do is they build a bunch of
different
sized models with different
patch resolutions so this see the
resolution
is always the number after the slash
right so here this would be 16 by 16. so
obviously the lower this number the
higher the
the resolution where the the higher the
resolution
in which the model looks at the picture
right
now one advantage here is
that uh compared to for example vision
transformers
is that vision transformers of course
due to the attention mechanism
they have a quadratic requirement of
compute and memory
as they go as they increase the sequence
length which means
as they lower this number right here
their number of patches in the image
increases and therefore
they suffer quadratically while this
model
only suffers linearly from this and
that is the point they make here in the
experiments so
the experiments is it's sort of a
repeating pattern and the repeating
pattern is
you know if you look at the best models
and let's say
imagenet top one or or very good models
we're not quite as good right if you
know
depending on so they pre-train
they pre-train on large data sets and
then they transfer learn
or they linearly classify the frozen
features
and the story is always the same it's
yeah you look at us
we are sometimes you know even better
than this but we're not we're not quite
as good as this
uh however
we are competitive right that's the the
the the core message here is that we are
competitive you know competitive you
know if if this had been
on the market a couple of years ago this
would have been state of the art by far
but now the this model is it's
competitive it achieves
okay performance and since
that's not what we like to hear in
machine learning publishing
uh i think that the big lesson if you
want to publish something here is that
find a metric where you win
okay so they say you know we might not
be the best ones
in classification accuracy however
we're okay and we have a better
trade-off
so there are a number of trade-offs they
look at right here for example
throughput
you see this right here throughput
images
per second per core during inference
this is something that's
really important to practitioners to
people that actually have to deploy
these models right and you can see that
the throughput of mixer here
is way above these other models of
course uh because
you know convolutions here they're you
know they're a difficult operation and
also this this big transfer model
it has a lot more layers uh i think
than the the mixer or vision transformer
and of course the vision transformer
itself has that attention mechanism so
not only does it have that quadratic
requirement it also has the
sort of computation of the soft max
itself and so on
and also uh if you look at
how much you had to put into training
um in this case vision transformer is
actually outperforming
mixer uh but in all of these tables
you always have at least one metric
where mixer is better
you just have to select the metric so
for example um
[Music]
you you can see that
well this i like this more
so here it's linear five shot imagenet
top one so if i understand this
correctly
this is you train a linear classifier on
the frozen
representation of what the model gives
you you evaluate it on top one accuracy
but you get
um it's a it's a five shot classifier
okay so it's a very particular task
and they look at what happens if
we modify the training set
size so the size that we train on
and you can see that
in this framing this model
scales much more favorably than
other models so big transfer which is
good
at you know low data set size all of a
sudden plateaus
and doesn't increase any more or much
more
when you scale up the data set by a
significant factor
however the mixer model scales
really well and in fact at the end
is on par almost sometimes with the
vision transformer
even here it's even a bit higher right
and specifically it's also higher than
the big transfer
model what you can also see is that
there is a significant gap
at small training data sets
however that gap also here that gap
always appears to close as you go up
so the gap here and here and here is way
smaller
and as we already said at the end very
often they are on top of one another
now this raises a bunch of interesting
questions this is by the way it's not
only this task
right they show this on a bunch of tasks
um
that it's the this model benefits from
scale
a lot more um it is it has a higher
throughput is a simpler architecture
yeah it scales in terms of what you need
to put in as compute
into pre-training and
so here you can see the imagenet
transfer accuracy
compared to how many core days on a tpu
v3
you put in and you can see that the
mixer
and the transformer models they lie on
very much similar curves leading
actually leading the big transfer
model so they are computationally
more efficient and also here
in terms of throughput you can see that
for a given accuracy right mixer and
transformer have higher throughputs than
big transfer and for a given size of
model
uh mixer has a higher throughput than
vision transformer though vision
transformer makes up for that by being
more accurate they have
very very extensive evaluations to show
that they are you know that this model
is something i believe this model is
something
that if you really care about deploying
it to large scales
you might want to take that performance
hit right
uh in you know to trade off for better
throughput
i think that's that's fairly clear from
these evaluations
now it remains to be seen how this model
performs
in different settings for different data
for different tasks
and so on and when this is imagenet and
imagenet after pre-training
with particular data sets so here they
pre-train on imagenet
itself and you know if you pre-train on
a small data set
the the model sucks right it really
trails
it really trails other models you can
see right here
if you pre-train on a slightly larger
data set
it still sucks but it doesn't suck as
much
compared to others if you pre-train on a
really big data set
you can see that it only sucks a little
a little bit um so you you're
hard-pressed to find
a number here that's higher and that's i
think the point
they make now the interesting question
for me
is is this like how does this go on
as we go higher like as we go one order
of magnitude higher in our data set and
compute and so on is it the case that
the mixer continues rising
while the vision transformer sort of
plateaus out
which would be really interesting
because
you could you could then make the case
that the vision transformer actually has
more inductive biases than
the um the mixer because
both seem very general right and i would
personally argue that the vision
transformer
is more general and has less inductive
biases because
here the mixer first of all the weights
are fixed and second of all
there's this very particular chessboard
pattern
to how you interact with the input data
right
it almost seems like um there
are lots of biases here now these things
these this inductive bias might be just
super duper duper
correct for the particular modality
we're dealing with like
in natural image classification
or it might actually be that the mixer
transfers to other domains and
works really well in which case i might
be wrong
it also might be the case of course that
both
plateau in which case that would just
mean uh
with enough scale you can get pretty
much anything to work
right um so you know if you're cynic
you can say well even a crap
architecture like mixture
you can get to work by just scaling it
up and using sgd
and yeah which
might also be true ultimately in the
limit of scale
as you have the entire possibility of
all images
as your data set you can of course just
perform a k nearest neighbor
classification
and you'd be correct 100
of the time i don't think we're there
yet with the scale
but the this sort of trend is relatively
clear but it will be really interesting
to see
how that goes on after you know after
our current limits
the last thing they show here is the the
weights
and so they make a couple of interesting
let's say um interesting
observations here these are the token
mixing weights
so every point here corresponds to sort
of one
patch in the original image so this is
how do you aggregate information within
the same channel
across different patches right and
they make some observations namely for
example that
the weights here appear for example in
pairs of negative positive so blue and
red here
are high and low values
also in the lower layer so if i'm
correct this is the the first
the second and the third uh block
so this this is the lower layer down
here
and the high layer is here you can see
that in the lower layer
you have rather large scale general
features that are learned
while as as you go higher you have much
more
specific interaction specific
weights that you learn and this all
is very reminiscent let's say of how
we think or how we observe convolutional
neural networks
work so it's a good case here that the
model learns something
that it is that is sensible you can
watch all of these weights i think they
have it in the appendix they have
um the full weights right here also
pre-trained on different
data sets and and this is really
interesting too so if you pre-train on
imagenet
it looks qualitatively different than if
you pre-train on
imagenet 21k which is just it's a it's
it's larger with more classes and that's
also significantly
different than if you pre-train on this
jft 300m
which is a super huge data set that's
proprietary
held by google
and it's still i think that
it's still unclear whether these
differences are an effect of scale
or an effect of how how
how accurate the downstream model is so
like
let's say an effect of
how well how much signal there is to
learn
independent of scale or whether it is
actually just a property of the data
sets being of a different
nature and that would also explain why
imagenet and imagenet 21k
are seem to be a bit closer together
visually
than jft 300m no
don't forget that jft is a huge data set
the code is open source in fact it's
right here uh
you just take it also i've seen or
already a bunch of people
implement this so this was it for me for
this paper again this is not it's not
very complicated uh it's it's a very
simple architecture which
is exactly its selling point its selling
point is
it's simple and that means it can scale
up
really well its trade-off between
compute and accuracy
is really good and you should consider
it
if that's something that's of importance
to you
from a research perspective it raises a
lot of questions
about inductive biases how scale behaves
and whether you can get
anything and everything to work with sgd
and
a lot of tpus that's it thanks for
listening
i'll see you next time bye